Speaker 1: Ladies and gentlemen, my April
Fools joke was an overwhelming success
and also backfired very, very badly. On
Saturday, April 1st, I put out a video
called I'm Leaving YouTube. The Mob.
One of the show is over. That video,
as of this recording, has more than half a million
views. Overwhelmingly, people understood that it's
a joke, and part of the reason you could tell it
was a joke is in the video I say that the right
wing mob took everything that our toilets aren't
even flushing at the studio and that I'm having to
flush 10 to 15 times. Now, that's a reference to
Trump's obsession with toilets. The entire thing
was a joke, but one of the things that is a this
is sort of a math thing, okay? And I realize this.
If 500,000 people see the video and 99.9% realize
it's a joke, if 0.1% don't realize it's a joke,
that's still 500 people who think I'm
being serious. And of those 500 people,
half might email me. Now, I think in reality
the numbers are more like 99.5% of the audience
realized that was a joke, but about half
of 1% didn't. When these are the numbers,
that's thousands of people. And I received
hundreds of emails saying, David, I'm so sorry
that this is happening. I can't believe
it. Brian Tyler Cohen, fellow YouTuber,
texted me and said, Hey, people are contacting
me saying, you've got to help David Pakman. He
needs help. They're taking his show. Can
you get him a lawyer? Can you help him?
I heard from actors and politicians that I didn't
even know had any idea who I was saying. David,
I'm really upset. Can I. Can I get you
an agent? Can I get you? How can I help
you get the show back? And I explained to
everybody it's just an April Fools joke,
but it is really something else. A
couple of the messages that I got
here is one, this. This. I really found this one
funny, Jill commented. My husband called out to
me while I was in another room. Pacman is ending
the show. The Anti-woke mob won and I called back.
Today is April 1st. I love this. I'm visualizing
Jill's husband yelling from the other room, and
Jill immediately knows what's going on and says
it's April 1st. And then Jill's husband goes, Oh,
and then goes right back to it. But Jill did say,
I would have believed it if I saw the video first.
I got a bunch of different voicemails about this.
Speaker 4: Here's one elbow, David, please stick
with it. Don't let them son of a bitch is put you
out of business. You're stronger than they are.
I don't think they got God on their side
when it gets down to it. Just keep up
the good fight and help us out.
Speaker 1: Yeah, well, listen,
we're okay. We're okay. I did get a second
voice. I actually got hundreds of voicemails
about this. I just picked two.
Speaker 2: Hey, David, this
is the news from Minnesota.
Speaker 4: I just want to tell you.
Speaker 2: That we're with you
and we're. This is awful, what's
happening. And I'd like to see you get back on.
Speaker 4: Anyway, if there's anything I can
do to help, let us. Let us know. Okay.
Speaker 1: So, listen, I appreciate the
outpouring of support after the right wing mob
did come after me. We are not canceled. In fact,
March on YouTube was one of our best months in
a long time, thanks to the right wing mob. They
generated such interest in what we are doing.
And of course, the bad faith takes about what
we did led to a backlash where we actually
I'm so grateful to everybody is the point.
One other aspect to this, which I have to say
has been so uplifting. Some people wrote to me
and said, David, you know, I realized it was
an April Fool's joke by the end of the video.
But in the first 40, 50 seconds, I thought it
was for real. And I was so upset that it made
me realize how much I value what you do. I was
taking it for granted. And then when you said
that they won, that they canceled you, I became so
upset that I realized I really should actually be
supporting the show if I was this upset at the
prospect of the show being canceled. It made
me realize I actually really value this. And I
should I should get a membership for a couple of
bucks. And a couple dozen people wrote to me about
that. So, listen, if you were upset by the joke,
it's just a joke. Okay. That's all it is. The show
is here. We had a fantastic march. We are here.
We've got so much going on. We're pushing into the
primaries, the Trump indictment, the arraignment,
all of it, the 2024 election. And I appreciate
every single person in the audience, including
everybody who has started new support over the
last week. Let's keep going. Let's press forward.